[Musique]
pendant mon colonel
je peux voir entre de manoeuvre c'est
très gentil de votre part
oh excusez vous ai pas dit bonjour
pendant enfin salut oui non enfin
bonjour non excusez-moi je suis pas
encore complètement familier avec vous
vos rita mais je somme ça commence à
venir
oui je suis le chasseur de la guérinière
j'ai été incorporé à quoi une semaine et
j'avoue qu'il ya deux trois petites
choses dont j'aimerais vous entretenir
c'est pas grave grave mais si vous
prenez en compte ce que je vais vous
dire où je pense qu'on peut aller vers
un peu plus de confort
non tant que principaux buts je sais
mais c'est le temps un plus pour le
moral des troupes
si vous aussi vous voulez sait pas quand
ça va pas commencer le jeu mass pas
puisque angers puis des exercices toute
la journée
oui oui d'abord une truc tout bête c'est
la tenue vous faites porter qui est très
sport j'en conviens mais alors la
couleur qui s'est occupé du choix de la
couleur alors qu'à qui ne l'est pas
taper dans le tas pur vise un bon début
j'ai pensé à un blanc cassé mais j'ai
peur un peu salissant pour les exercices
que vous faites fer eba un petit rouge
bordeaux qu'est ce que vous en pensez
aa oui c'est vrai ça pas facilité le
camouflage on peut rester dans le vert
temps qui sépare la couleur que je
préfère ma soi même si j'habite à y sera
plus avenant là et que d arrêter de dire
non comme ça sans réfléchir chaque fois
que moi meilleur de repos chf un peu de
couture
je vais vous montrer un modèle en
décidera après non bon je ne suis pas
bon ça c'est une première chose
maintenant c'est au sujet de la cantine
on lit beaucoup trop salaires table
avait déjà les bandages imagine une
question de budget les armes en étapes
de 6 ans et coire 10 dessus non j'ai
conscience que ce n'est pas l'hôtel me
regarde bien on est serré donc on mange
mal donc on digère mal oui à barrer
doutes envers au combat
on est bâillonnée et vous appliquez
tellement d'espacé toutes ces manoeuvres
ses forêts ses champs de mines que nous
on arrive à la cantine aux
claustrophobes
si vous pouvez en glisse un mot
l'architecte je pense que ça serait pas
du luxe
bon a tenu la cantine ça s'est réglé à
tous les matins il ya un type faut
absolument trouver qui c'est qui sur les
coups de 6 heures jeux de la trompette
ou de cette faute juste parce que c'est
comme instrument et ça réveille tout le
monde puisse y joue pratiquement
toujours la même chose c'est irritant
enfin quelque chose a assez du clairon
c'est possible je ne suis pas très
mélomane il fait exprès il vous ici ah
oui mais la nation à ses dires c'est
beaucoup trop tôt non moi je vois si
j'ai pas mes huit heures semaine je vais
casser quand vous amenez capacités non
mais vous êtes très agréable pour un
militaire se poser de questions mais je
trouve que vous exagérez un peu la grève
pendant 1 vous allez offrir une chambre
individuelle
j'en ai pas tant pendant une semaine
jean rien à faire mais c'est très
agréable de votre femme je voudrais pas
non plus si c'est la jalousie chez mes
camarades qui se veut vous incitez
d'accès mais c'est une bosse des petits
lotissements individuel c'est quoi ah ça
existe depuis toujours on the bell le
new ça sonne bien mais c'est pas un
geste vous allez regretter
bah écoutes je parle c'est par amour
me passer voir à l'occasion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]